ahora vamos a hablar de uno de los
conceptos más útiles en la vida
probablemente que muy probablemente sea
conocido sino este vídeo podría ayudarte
tal vez a no caer en la bancarrota en
algún momento de tu vida bien entonces
vamos a hablar de los intereses y
después vamos a hablar de intereses
compuestos contra intereses simples
entonces qué son los intereses todos
hemos escuchado hablar de tasas de
interés intereses de hipótesis sobre
hipotecas cuánto interés de bueno mi
tarjeta de crédito no sé cuál es la
definición exacta de intereses debería
de buscar una wikipedia tal vez pero
bueno básicamente es la renta sobre el
dinero es dinero que yo pago por
mantener yo durante cierta cantidad de
tiempo dinero digamos que quiero pedir
prestado 100 pesos
ahorita
y bueno vamos a decir que aquí vamos a
poner aquí dentro de un año
ok y este eres tú el que va a prestar
los 100 pesos y este soy yo entonces
ahorita tú me prestas 100 pesos y yo
tengo los 100 pesos durante un año
y si te regresar a esos 100 pesos dentro
de un año tú habrías obtenido nada por
prestarme los 100 pesos durante un año
no habría obtenido ningún interés pero
si tú me dices que me prestes prestó los
100 pesos si tú dentro de un año me
prestas me regresa 110 pesos
en esta situación cuánto te pague yo
porque me he prestado 100 pesos pues te
regresa 10 pesos de más no te bueno te
regreso los 100 pesos que me prestas te
y después te voy a regresar otros 10
pesos entonces estos 10 pesos es estos
10 pesos extras es esencialmente lo que
yo te estoy pagando para durante un año
de guardar tu dinero y usarlo como yo
quiera entonces esencialmente esos diez
pesos son el interés que es un
porcentaje de ese dinero que tú me
prestas te digamos un porcentaje ya que
en terminología de finanzas le llamamos
principal
entonces en este caso la renta sobre el
dinero o el interés fueron 10 pesos pero
si lo quiero ver como un porcentaje
tendría que poner lo que hay el interés
10 sobre el principal 100 lo cual
equivale al 10% entonces podría decirme
ok estoy dispuesto a prestar de 100
pesos siempre y cuando tú me pagues el
10% interés entonces bueno al 10% de 100
pesos fueron 10 pesos esto yo tendré que
pagar en un año los 100 pesos más 10
pesos y bueno podrías decir esto para
cualquier cantidad no podrías hacerlo
como para mil pesos
si me prestas mil pesos entonces el
interés debería de ser 100 pesos que son
el 10% de mil y no entonces dentro de un
año
debería los mil pesos más el 10% de los
mil pesos
y bueno eso es igual a 1100 pesos
entonces mil pesos son es el principal y
los 100 pesos que es el 10 por ciento de
los mil pesos es el interés bueno ahora
acá vamos a hacer la distinción entre
interés simple e interés compuesto bueno
hicimos un ejemplo muy fácil o sea me
presta 100 pesos a un interés del 10%
pero bueno ahora vamos a tomar un
interés yo creo que también el 10 por
ciento por año nos queda muy bien es un
buen interés
y te voy a pedir prestado un principal
que sea de un tamaño de 100 pesos otra
vez
entonces la pregunta es si tal vez le
quieras poner pausa y pensarlo y luego
regresar
cuánto te debo cuánto dinero te debo yo
después de diez años
a cuánto dinero te debo yo en diez años
con un interés de diez por ciento por
año y con un principal de 100 pesos hay
dos formas de pensar lo gay entonces
empezamos en el año cero
ok el año cero es nada sol y no te lo
regrese inmediatamente no te debo ningún
interés en que hay 100 pesos no voy a
hacer eso ok lo voy a mantener por lo
menos un año pero bueno después de un
año cuánto te debo yo según lo que
acabamos de hacer te debo 110 pesos no o
sea son los 100 pesos del principal más
el interés del 10% de 100 pesos que son
10 pesos usted 2 110 pesos entonces en
el después de dos años le tengo que
agregar otro 10% no entonces en este
caso serían 120 pesos
y en el año 3 serían 130 pesos
esencialmente mi renta por año son 10
pesos
huddle entonces son ya le estamos
agregando el 10% al principal original a
100 pesos
ok entonces después de 10 años te
debería yo 200 pesos
ya que son 100 pesos el principal
original más otros 100 pesos de interés
porque te pago diez pesos por año
y esta noción de lo que vamos a hacer se
llama interés simple que es
esencialmente tomamos el principal
original que son los 100 pesos y cada
año la renta por porque me prestas tu
dinero es el 10% de lo que me prestas te
del principal original si lo piensas
cada año te estoy pagando un porcentaje
cada vez más chico no o sea porque entre
en el después de dos años de 220 pesos y
entonces en el tercer año que estaría yo
pagamos 130 que no es el 10% de 120
bueno y ahora vamos a ver cómo es el
interés compuesto empezamos otra vez
principal de 100 pesos y después de un
año te debo igual 110 pesos que es el
principal más el 10% ley son 100 pesos
más el 10% de 100 pesos déjame cambio
del color
y aquí es donde donde hay una diferencia
entre el simple y el compuesto en el
simple y vamos aumentando 10% del
principal original en el compuesto no
vamos a tomar el 10% del original ok
vamos a tomar el 10% de lo que te debo
cada año que después de un año son 110
pesos
entonces nuestro nuevo principal después
de un año va a ser 110 porque después de
un año tenemos 110
entonces tendría yo que pagar después
del segundo año 110 más el 10% de 110 y
eso es igual a lo podemos distribuir
y termina siendo igual a 110
el 1 del 110 más punto 1 del 10 por
ciento entonces nos queda 1.1 ok y eso
es igual bueno lo puedo volver a
escribir pero con el principal original
no que siento por 1.1 al cuadrado
que son 121 pesos y en el año 2 nuestro
nuevo principal es 121 este
entonces en el año 3 este es el año 2
todo esto es el año 2 tomando más
espacio en el año 3 voy a tener que
pagar te los 121 pesos que te debía yo
al inicio del año más el 10% de este
nuevo principal que 121 que es lo que
todavía yo al inicio de este año
y bueno si lo distribuimos
tenemos 1 % 21 más el 10% de 121 jaqués
1.1 por ciento 21 otra forma de
escribirlo ya desde el original el
principal original es 100 por 1.1 a la
tercera potencia y si seguimos haciendo
esto y deberías hacerlo para que veas
como funciona bien después de 10 años yo
te debería a ti 100 pesos por 1.1 a la
décima potencia que déjame sacar mi hoja
de excel escogemos una celda lozada
y ponemos 100 pesos
por 1.1 la décima potencia y son 259
pesos y un poco de cambio bien
no escribamos lo por acá 259 pesos
entonces parecía que había una
diferencia muy pequeña entre el interés
simple y el interés compuesto pero
después de 10 años hay casi 60 pesos de
diferencia
con un interés compuesto te debo 259
pesos pero con interés simple nada más
te debo 200 pesos
entonces hay 59 pesos de más con el
interés compuesto voy a hacer unos
cuantos ejemplos más en los próximos
vídeos pero bueno trata de entender bien
bien cuál la diferencia entre interés
simple y interés compuesto